Benefit Cosmetics is one
of the top beauty brands
for eyebrow products.
Its Precisely, My Brow pencil
is one of its best-
selling products.
On average, it sells one
brow pencil every two seconds.
Talk about popular!
To learn a bit more
about what makes
this brow pencil such a favorite,
we got a look
behind the scenes
of how it's made at
Benefit's Tokyo factory.
The process begins with
a variety of pigments.
White,
black,
yellow,
and red pigments
go into the pencil.
Those pigments are
combined with ingredients
such as stearic acid, which
helps to thicken the mixture
and prevent the pencil
from smearing on your brow.
From there, wax
and oils are added
to bind all the
ingredients together.
Benefit's brow pencil requires
a variety of waxes and oils,
including fruit wax,
beeswax,
and coconut oil.
Once everything is combined,
the mixture is poured into
a large rolling machine.
The machine triple-
rolls the formula,
turning it into the
consistency of pencil shavings.
The loose mixture is then
compressed into a log shape,
which will become
the pencil's core.
More than 20,000
pieces of pencil core
will come from this
compressed mixture.
A machine cuts it ultra fine,
making each core
exactly the same.
Once the pencils are made,
there are two tests each
one has to go through
before it gets
packaged and shipped:
the shade test and
the durability test,
which are two of the
most important aspects
of what makes Benefit's
brow pencils so unique.
Deanna Tharp: So, what makes
the Precisely, My Brow pencil
different from any
other brow pencil,
I would say the shade range.
We suit every hair
color, every skin tone.
The other thing I love about it
is that it is a very durable
pencil for as tiny as it is.
You can put quite
a bit of pressure,
and that thing won't break.
Narrator: The shade test
makes sure each pencil
is the exact color
it's supposed to be.
To do this, the pencils
are meticulously swatched
and compared.
Benefit's pencils also go
through a durability test.
The core is tested to
make sure it can endure
up to 25 times its own
weight without breaking.
Next, the pencils are
hand-filled with the core.
Each pencil is
x-rayed to make sure
its quality and its
packaging are perfect.
The Precisely, My Brow
pencils are then hand-packed
and sent to stores in over 55
countries all over the world.